le fait du jour de ce lundi 25 mars
c'est donc l'ouverture d'une semaine de
sensibilisation au don de moelle osseuse
8e fois que cette semaine est organisée
toujours ce chiffre il manque 18000
donneurs en France Catherine Gougis donc
merci d'être venue sur ce plateau
puisque vous faites partie de ces
patients en attente justement de dont
vous êtes atteinte de thrombocyténie une
thrombocytémie essentielle alors je vous
laisse expliquer on appelle ça aussi une
hyperplaquéose c'est un dérèglement de
la moelle osseuse qui fait que le le
système de coagulation du sang qui est
lié aux plaquettes est complètement
déréglé donc on a normalement entre 250
et 400000 plaquettes dans une formule
sanguine normale et aujourd'hui je suis
à plus d'un million il y a un risque
très important pour la santé au-delà de
600000 tout à fait à partir de 600000 il
y a des risques non seulement
d'infarctus mais d'AVC et qui peuvent
être enrayé ou pas selon le moment où ça
se produit et l'environnement au moment
où ça se produit cela fait 26 ans que
vous connaissez cette maladie que vous
êtes suivi pour à l'hôpital Necker
d'ailleurs sur sur Paris pour autant ça
a évolué ces derniers mois oui ça a
évolué brutalement fin d'année avec une
grosse anémie que je n'avais pas vu
venir je pensais que c'était lié
simplement au changement de saison une
grosse fatigue et puis bien la la
formule sanguine qui montre cette anémie
qui m'oblige a arrêté la chimiothérapie
de longue durée qui est
l'yrea et des des prélèvements de
moileosuse pour faire un
diagnostic de cette évolution vers ce
qu'on appelle une légère mélofibrose qui
permet enfin qui qui fait que la la la
moileosuse est beaucoup moins oxygénée
et et aussi une mutation chromosomique
qui est extrêmement rare et pour
laquelle il n'existe pas de chimio donc
la seule issue pour moi est la greffe de
moelleosuse pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de traitement en attendant cette greffe
alors j'ai repris accessoirement le
traitement qu'on me donnait auuparavant
pour ralentir cette montée vertigineuse
de mes plaquettes et donc éviter ce
risque AVC infarctus et le traitement en
fait pour anti-agrégant plaquettaire est
simplement un petit aspectgic nourrisson
tous les soirs dou la nécessité donc de
donner c'est très simple on va vous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne dans un
instant on regarde juste ce court clip
c'est spot réalisé par l'agence de
biomédecine pour sensibiliser justement
la vie c'est souvent une question de
chance moi par exemple j'avais de champ
sur 20 d'avoir les yeux bleus 70 champ
sur 100 d'avoir mon permis de conduire
80 ch sur 100 de devenir mère une champ
sur 30000 de contracter une maladie du
sang heureusement une grffe de moosseuse
peut me guérir il existe une chance pour
que vous soyez le donneur compatible
dont j'ai
besoin ma chance c'est
vous semaine de sensibilisation au don
de la moelle osseuse nous en parlons ce
soir donc avec une y linoise sur le
plateau Catherine Gougis une petite
précision tout d'abord la moelle osseuse
ça correspond à quoi et si je vous pose
cette question c'est qu'avant l'émission
vous m'avez alerté vous m'avez dit le
don de Mo ossuse souvent on confond
souvent avec la MO épinière ENIT tout à
fait la moelle osseuse c'est l'usine du
sang c'est la fabrique c'est dans des
tissus mou des EOS plats et c'est là que
sont fabriqués les globules rouges les
globules blancs les rouges pour
l'oxygénation du du sang les blancs
contre les virus et microbes et les
plaquettes les plaquettes qui sont là
pour la éviter que le sang se coagu
qu'il y ait des hémorragies c'est le
système de coagulation c'est les trois
facteurs qui sont dans la moelleosseuse
et le fait que ce soit méconnu c'est ce
qui fait peur peut-être aussi oui parce
que les gens confondent aussi avec la
moelle épinière et pensent tout de suite
ponction lombaire chose très
douloureusees alors que donner de la
moelle ça n'est pas douloureux alors
vous vous informez le grand public au
quotidien parce que vous vous battez
véritablement pour informer les gens
chaque jour et vous serez aussi à la
Faculté de médecine de 50 ans en Yveline
des mercredis pour aussi médecin c'est
une opération nationale il y a 27
facultés de médecine à travers la France
qui vont qui vont y participer les
médecins aussi sont sont mal informés ou
il communique mal auprès de leurs futurs
patients aussi alors c'est très
difficile l'hématologie est quand même
quelque chose de très pointu et de
méconnu euh dire que j'ai un cancer du
sang ça paraît on comprend pas très bien
on dit j'ai un cancer du sein on
schématise où ça se trouve le sang c'est
insidieux et les équipes même les
médecins traitants sont un peu démuni
face à toutes ces maladies qui amènent à
la moileoseuse parce qu'on parle de la
leucémie mais il y a plusieurs leucémie
et ça on ne le sait pas on n'en parle
pas et on n'en parle pas assez
connaissez-vous le don de moelle osseuse
et aussi son importance c'est la
question que nous sommes allés vous
poser aujourd'hui dans les rues
saint-quanttin enven oui je pense que
c'est pour les personnes atteintes de
leucémie mais je ne suis pas très sûr de
moi non je pense que c'est très utile
mais je peux pas préciser j'ai pas fait
d'études monsieur pour ceux qui ont des
des
cancers du sang des des leucémies et
cetera non je vois pas exactement à part
pour sauver des vies je vois pas bah
c'est pour pour la moelle épinière c'est
pour faire des dons de moelle épinière
je connais les dons en général hein
celui-là pas pas en particulier non non
je connais le don du sang je connais le
dons du sperme mais pas le don de moelle
osseuse non je connais le don de moelle
osseuseon c'est pour certains certaines
maladies pour essayer de guérir
certaines maladies cancéreuses peut-être
le don est mal connu voilà pas
complètement inconnu mais en tout cas
mal connu c'est pour ça que que vous
informez et ce don qui est plutôt simple
entre 18 et 51 ans et il y a trois
façons de donner en fait oui alors la
façon la plus simple bon déjà il faut se
préinscrire pour devenir donneur il faut
déjà se préinscrire répondre à un
questionnaire médical avoir en entre 18
et 51 ans et on fait une petite prise de
sang pour déterminer le hl le HLA c'est
la carte d'identité du sang la carte
génétique ce qui va vraiment représenter
l'empreinte digitale du sang je dirais
et on fait 15 jours après une
confirmation de ce HL pour être sûr que
c'est bien déterminer correctement on va
pas abîmer les malades et c'est mis dans
un fichier on peut vous appeler ou ne
pas vous appeler mais si un malade a
besoin on va vous téléphoner on va vous
dire est-ce que vous êtes toujours
d'accord pour donner vous voulez
toujours bien venir on va vous refaire
un petit questionnaire médical du moment
et puis
euh et bien on va vous donner un petit
traitement pour exacerber ces cellules
souches qui sont contenu dans le sang de
façon je vais dire à à les faire
transpirer un petit peu puisqu'on ne va
récolter lors d'une grosse prise de sang
que ces cellules souches et on va vous
redonner le reste al il faut que ça
coïcide avec avec le donneur enfin entre
le donneur et le REC qu' une
compatibilité et quel est le pourcentage
de compatibilité alors il est requis au
moins 9/
10 bien sûr maintenant il y a des
travaux qui se font actuellement avec
des compatibilités moindres mais avec
des risques plus grands avec des
chimiothérapies consécutif plus lourde
lave souvent ce taux de 9/ 10 de de
compatibilité ça alors c'est très c'est
très rare c'est très rare parce qu'il y
a très peu de donneur 17 millions dans
le monde et seulement 200000 en
France 1700 greffes sont réalisées on
appelle ça des allogreffes sont réalisé
chaque année dont 200 pédiatriques
et il y a environ 3000 4000 leucémies
par an le nombre va aller en
grandissant c'est ce que prévoient les
médecins c'est ce que j'ai entendu à une
conférence à l'hôpital Saint-Antoine
samedi et donc on a de besoin en plus
besoin de donneur parce que si vous avez
une grande fratterie
un frère un enfant enfin un frère ou
sœur sur quatre peut être compatible
mais si vous nêtes
ENF ça devient for bien ça devient
presque une chance sur un million et ça
s'aggrave cette difficulté quand vous
faites partie d'une ethnie je vais dire
un peu complexe vous avez une origine
maghrébine d'un côté indienne de l'autre
et la mixité des deux sang fait que
c'est très très beau les métises les
sans mêl mais au niveau de la moelle
c'est très compliqué et pour donner il y
a trois façons un prélèvement de sang
vous l'avez abordé prélèvement aussi
dans l'os postérieur du bassin tout à
fait et puis il y a une un troisième cas
de figure sur lequel on va peut-être
s'attarder pour conclure cet entretien
c'est le don de cordon ombilical et ça
c'est peut-être aussi méconnu et
pourtant c'est assez simple on peut pas
faire plus simple c'est très simple la
maman enceinte dit qu'elle veut donner
le cordon
bilical elle le précise à la maternité
où elle est suivie lors de la naissance
quand on de chaque côté le cordon pour
le couper et bien on récupère cette
partie de cordon qui est congelée et ça
peut sauver un enfant qui a une leucémie
deux cordons compatibles sauvent un
adulte c'est très méconnu toutes les
maternités ne le font pas il faut bien
le préciser pour se mettre en situation
de c'est très r il y a que de maternités
deux hôpitaux sur la région qui qui le
font per alors sur les ivelines à ma
connaissance à moins qu'il y ait des
nouveautés très récentes il n'y a a pas
sur les ivelines de maternité il faut
aller à clamar à l'hôpital béclaire
l'hôpital de drereux le fait alors que
ce n'est pas une maternité très côté
mais c'est il faut vraiment œuvrer dans
ce sens pour que les maternités il
suffit que la sage femme ait la
formation pour récupérer ce cordon pour
sauver une vie et peut-être si on ne
sauve pas la vie permettre à la
recherche d'avancer et puis il reste le
don du sang tout simplement aussi hein
c'est c'est très très simple il suffit
de se rendre sur ce site Internet qui va
s'afficher don de moilosseuse.fr ou
encore un numéro de téléphone que vous
pouvez contacter vous aurez toutes les
informations pour être d'honneur entre
18 51 ans en bonne santé et ça suffit
voilà merci Catherine Gougis pour ce
témoignage vous savez maintenant que ce
don moosseuse est simple et gratuit et
puis il y aura aussi ce stand que vous
tiendrez ces animations que vous allez
faire à la Faculté de médecine il y a
tris jours d'animation à la Faculté de
Médecine he c'est s'appelle les
étiudients solidaires 27 27 fac en
France et donc il faut
que ces étudiants soient mobilisés merci
à vous à suivre dans le 78 Opera sport
mais déjà vous allez découvrir le visage
de la nouvelle misseline l'élection qui
se déroulait ce weekend dans un centre
commercial à morpa en présence de Miss
France Charlotte Pauline alisé Kim au
total 15 beautés ont défilé ce samedi
dans le centre commercial Paris Ouest de
morpa pour décrocher le titre convoité
de miel 2013 je postule aujourd'hui dans
l'ESP de pouvoir représenter la femme
aujourd'hui de nos jours qui est
indépendante et ambieuse voilà après la
parade en robe de soirée les jeunes
femmes sont passées en maillot de bain
toujours en talon haut en musique et
sous les encouragements du public un
événement placé sous le signe du glamour
en présence de notre Miss France 10000 €
je suis pas là pour juger voilà je suis
vraiment là pour leur donner des
conseils si elles m'en demande et je
leur dirai simplement de de profiter de
ces momentsl pour s'amuser pour d'être
souriante de de montrer qu'elles sont
contentes d'être là tout simplement le
chemin
débute sera long jusqu'à l'écharpe de
Miss France mais il y en aura une et et
moi je serai très contente l'année
prochaine de remettre mon
écharpe venu soutenir les candidates
marine l'orphelin en a profité pour une
rencontre dédicace avec ses
fans pendant ce temps le jury délibéré
et les apprentis m patientai avec leurs
proches parmi elles Anaïs pour laquelle
nous avions eu un coup de cœur elle est
voque avant le résultat les qualités
pour être élu faut être souriante c'est
important il faut être soi-même et faut
avoir de la grâce et voilà faut savoir
bien s s'exprimer aussi et puis être
belle
j'imagine c'est sa maman originaire de
la Martinique qui l'a inscrite
secrètement à l'élection dans l'espoir
qu'elle soit sacrée je seraai très
fierre de ma fille très fier et puis
pour sa mamie aussi qui n'est plus là et
qui trouvait qu'elle avait une chance
aussi d'être élu Miss France ou Miss
Eveline et justement Miss yeline 2013
est la candidate numéro
4ï sur fond d'hyne officiel du comité
Miss France le rêve commence pour
l'étudiante en BTS tourisme à gu encour
je suis surpris je suis heureuse et
voilà plein de bonnes choses qui vont
arrivriver j'imagine sortez la date le
26 juin Anaïs du haut de son maître 71
participera à l'élection Miss Île de
France